[Music]
this is tactus technologies tactile
touch screen on a hacked 7-inch Android
tablet it's a panel that looks like a
flat touchscreen but actually raises
based on your touch say for instance if
you are using an app that needs a
keyboard the buttons for the keys will
actually raise up it works by having
some fluid between the polymer of the
panel and an elastic covering and then
the fluid is able to push the elastic up
for the keys it's a pretty cool concept
considering how hard it is to type on
flat touchscreens though tactus hasn't
named any partners yet I think it would
be pretty cool to have these on smaller
tablets or maybe even phones it feels
pretty good and you know I would like to
have it on my tablet